我听说今年(2025年)4月
台湾有一个
40岁左右的工程师
在一家半导体公司在工作
休假的时候
他很认真还回去加班
收假的时候
竟然的被同事们发现
他在无尘室里面
猝死了
听起来很难过
对你每天拼命赚钱
却忘了身体
才是你的本钱
胡乃文开讲啰
我是你的老朋友胡医师
这一集要特别分享给
三餐不正常轮班族
长期过劳的科技人
或是上班族
我会教你简单的方法
帮你找回健康
还没订阅的人赶快订阅
把这一集分享给你身边
很努力工作的好朋友们喔
三餐不正常胃闷痛
1招养好脾胃
年薪百万的科技人啊
身体最常出现
这三大危机
吃不好睡不好压力大
最常见的就是胃不好
出现的小毛病
胃食道逆流胃溃疡
甚至胀气便秘
来想养好脾胃
我跟你说一个简单的方法
你每天上班前
帮自己准备好食物
没时间煮的人
你可以去超商买地瓜
茶叶蛋蒸玉米
或是一瓶豆浆
比较有时间的人
你用电锅炖好
四神汤小米粥
放在焖烧罐里
这两道
都能养护你的脾胃
趁工作有空档
赶紧吃那么一口吧
我再说一次
工作再忙也不能不吃
就算只是吃几口食物
都比你空腹
让胃酸一直分泌
要来得好喔
胃常常闷痛的人
来按这个穴
它叫做内关穴
在手腕的横纹
往上三个指头
在这个两个筋的中间
按压一两分钟
这个穴可以舒缓
胃痛胃胀和恶心反胃
是啊胃如果顾得好
人生是彩色的啦
脾胃一坏喔
整组都坏掉了
全身都出问题
很多慢性病
都是从脾胃失调而来
别小看
没时间吃饭的代价
空腹太久
胃酸一直刺激黏膜
先是胃闷痛
再变成胃食道逆流
加上你是常常
吃饭吃太快的人
你就成功的把脾胃弄坏掉
轮夜班睡不
好喝 1茶护肝降伤害
科技业工程师最怕的
不只是加班赶进度
而是日班小夜大夜轮不停
还要随时On Call
作息很乱
身体就像电脑
一直没有关机
久了你就会遇到三个东西
自律神经失调三高
还有伤了肝
第一个自律神经失调
长期的作息混乱
交感神经好像按了
快转的按钮
心跳加快脑子停不下来
结果就是睡不着
睡不好怎么办
你先按一按
你先按一按神门穴
神门穴在哪个地方呢
它是在手腕的横纹上
在小指跟无名指之间的
这一条线上
睡前按压左手右手
左手右手这样
各按它个
一两分钟
帮你舒缓紧张更快入睡
轮班族最容易
白天想睡
晚上却很清醒
他免疫系统
代谢都全往下掉了
想让自己舒服一点
你可以用光来提醒身体
补眠的时候
房间一定要暗
够暗才行
拉上窗帘或者戴个眼罩
让身体知道
现在是晚上不是白天
褪黑激素才会开始分泌
醒来以后
不管什么时间
一定要接触光线
例如晒晒太阳
告诉大脑现在是白天
让身体找回正常的节奏
睡不好还会引发更大的问题
血压血糖血脂肪都会飙高
甚至于还伤到肝
新竹有一位肝胆肠胃科医生
他说他的慢性肝炎病人里头
有一半是科学园区轮班的工作人员
他们只要
轮班或者超时工作
肝功能指数
就开始瞬间的往上飙升
这就是爆肝的警告了
别让轮班透支你的肝
来喝一杯
枸杞菊花茶
养肝顾眼睛
枸杞里的枸杞多糖
能够稳定血糖
菊花能降火气降血压
让血管更健康
降低轮班的问题
长时间憋尿
1茶饮护肾防泌尿科病
年轻的工程师
在实验室里头工作
因为防尘衣穿脱不方便
可能半天整天都穿着
连上厕所的时间都变少了
有工程师说他
一天只喝两杯水
一杯中午吃完饭后喝
一杯下班前喝
整天下来他只上了两次厕所
长期这样做
就是肾脏泌尿系统
出大问题的候选人了
我们一般人的排尿量
是每两个小时一次
一天大概会上7到8次厕所
而他只上了
两次
那就太少了
尿液在膀胱里滞留太久
容易造成尿道膀胱的发炎
严重的就可能出现
血尿
这种情况小编说是
职灾啦
所谓的职业灾害
对呀像美发师
警察医生
也会遇到这样的问题
不错我们当医生的都知道
就是有的时候长期的
不能够赶快起来上厕所
科技人或主管们
别只顾赚钱
身体弄坏了
要想保养好泌尿道
很简单
我教你两招
第一泌尿道不舒服的人
来喝一杯白茅根茶
白茅根能清热利尿
舒缓泌尿道的不适应
白茅根怎么喝
你准备一两的白茅根
到药房去买
清洗干净以后
用1000cc的水来煮
煮滚之后转小火
继续煮大概20分钟
就可以喝了
没有空煮的人
可以用马克杯
用热水冲下去
对常常要熬夜加班
压力大的人
你可以在办公室里
用热水焖泡着这样喝
提醒你
两种人不要喝
体质虚寒
那些吹一点风就怕冷的人
还有月经期间的人不要喝
第二就是
口渴了要喝水
想上厕所不要憋着
千万不要憋尿
这是保护泌尿道
最好的方法
24小时on call
工作压力大
1呼吸法快速放松
如何克服压力
压力不会自己消失
但你可以学习暂时把它放掉
来推荐你一个
很好用的呼吸法
它叫做紧张消除呼吸法
做法非常简单
鼻子吸气3秒
再从嘴巴吐气6秒排出来
也有人把它叫做
1:2 呼吸法
美丽的太太
我们来感受一下
这个呼吸法好吗
好啊
来我们先
吸气三秒
再嘴巴吐气六秒
再吸气三秒
嘴巴吐气六秒
我们现在做一做看
吸23
呼23456
你做这一种呼吸法的时候
吐气要慢慢的吐
像拉长的丝线一样
把压力一点一点的释放
美丽的太太
刚才觉得效果怎么样
不错啊
感觉很轻松
感觉轻松了很多是吧
好
你在办公室捷运上
甚至在睡前做
都能让你舒缓焦虑和紧张
很方便的
这个呼吸法是来自日本
自律神经研究权威
叫小林弘幸教授
它能活化你的副交感神经
并且增加血液循环
让氧气顺利送到
全身各个角落
肌肉自然放松
紧绷的感觉就会逐渐消失
赚钱却丢了性命
这样做找回健康
前几年在科学园区
发生过一件事
一个财务副总
在连续加班之后
心肌梗塞最后成了植物人
他本身就有高血压
甚至曾经在公司
已经昏倒过两次
真正的发病的时候
才四十多岁
正是壮年
可以做最多事的时候
树根要是稳固
就不怕树梢被台风吹袭
你应该先把自己照顾好
才能安然的
面对生活的风雨
你曾经想过
人为什么
过度卖命会生病吗
中医讲
天人合一
人的作息脏腑的运行
其实是要遵循
自然的节律生活的
我们每一个人
都只有24小时
太阳升的时候
就该起来上班工作对不对
太阳下山的时候
就应该要休息
该要睡觉的时候就去睡
该醒的时候就醒
这个可以说是
老天爷安排的
身体固定的规律
如果你违背了
会发生什么事
身体就开始跟你抗议了
生病肿瘤癌症
什么都来跟你纠缠
搞得你痛不欲生
也不一定
我再说一次
奉劝各位
不要再糟蹋你的身体了
努力工作值得赞许
但是你长期的这样糟蹋
滥用你的身体
可就不是一个
负责任的行为了
真正的富足不只是赚钱
还要有一个健康的身体
才能好好生活
爱自己是你能给自己
最珍贵的礼物
对
亲爱的粉丝们
我们已经开启会员频道了
如果你认同我推广中医
照顾自己健康的理念
欢迎每月小额支持
只要花两杯咖啡的钱喔
或成为VIP赞助者
有你同行
我们才能走得更远
真心感谢你哦